[Music]
welcome everyone to this latest how the
light gets in
uh festival talk it's my absolute
delight and pleasure to
have the chance to talk with michael
sandel about
his new book the tyranny of merit so
michael let's just start if i may
with uh just the title the tyranny of
merit can you give us a
a sense of the overall thrust of the
book
yes merit on the face of it seems a good
thing who could be against
giving people jobs or assigning social
roles on the basis of
merit and yet in our time
so it seems to me jesse merit has has
become
a tyranny especially when
the way we define merit is largely based
on the money people
make as if that were a true measure of
their contribution to the common good
the basic idea of the book is this for
decades
the divide between winners and losers
has been deepening it's been poisoning
our politics
driving us apart the problem is partly
the deepening inequality of income and
wealth that has come about as a result
of globalization
but it's not only that it has also to do
with the changing attitudes toward
success and failure that have come with
it
those who've landed on top have come to
believe
that their success is their own doing
the measure of their merit and by
implication
that those who've been left behind
have no one to blame but themselves this
is the harsh
side of the meritocratic promise and the
book is about
really how we've how we've landed
in this deeply polarized political
condition
and how the way we've understood
merit and meritocracy has reinforced the
divide
and then finally how we might begin to
climb out of it
so uh at the beginning then you would
you were talking about
the oppressive effect that
what you might call a uh not just the
focus on merit but the idea of a
meritocracy in principle might
have on those uh in a way a corrupting
effect
at the top end people come to believe
their own pr
and and at the bottom end uh because
somehow people are being instructed by
some elite to believe that they
deserve the place that they've been
allocated in in some way if i've
understood that
tell me about um that that's is that
what you really think of as meritocratic
hubris
it's a very it's a very kind of it's a
wonderful way of describing this problem
yes by meritocratic hubris
i mean the tendency of the successful
to inhale too deeply of their success
to forget the luck and good fortune that
helped them on their way
and to assume that since they consider
that they have risen
thanks to their efforts and talents
the tendency to look down on those who
haven't
to assume that they must simply lack
the effort and hard work and talent to
flourish
in the new economy and a big part of
this perhaps we'll get to it
jesse is the idea that the way to
compete and win in the global economy is
to get a four-year university degree the
idea being
that the answer to the inequalities that
have
deepened is simply or primarily
individual upward mobility through a
university degree
this induces a kind of credentialism
among the winners who come to over
valorize
the possession of the university degree
and it leads
to a kind of demoralization even
humiliation among those
who don't have a university degree who
after all
are the majority of our fellow citizens
nearly two-thirds we easily forget this
nearly two-thirds of our fellow citizens
in the uk and in the u.s
do not have a four-year university
degree so it's folly to have created an
economy that sets
as a condition of dignified work and a
decent life
a four-year university degree one of the
things that's so catching uh
about the book and arresting indeed
about it is uh
um the moment at the beginning where you
talk about your own experience
with uh your students at harvard and
i suppose two things one is uh how they
are all without fail attribute their
success in having made it to harvard to
the uh
unaided brilliance and uh um
laborious hard work uh that they've put
in
uh and also their utter uh
unawareness that actually in many ways
uh american
social mobility is uh thoroughly uh
second rate by international standards
because i'll come to the students in a
moment but
for for many years in america we've
consoled ourselves with the greater
degree of inequality in our society than
in many
european societies for example saying
here we don't need to worry much
about inequality because we have a
mobile society
no one is consigned to the class
of his or her birth unlike those
class-ridden
societies of europe which do worry so
much about inequality
we are an upwardly mobile society so we
we don't need to worry about it and this
may actually account for
the rather less generous welfare state
that the u.s has by comparison with the
uk
and european social democracies
but this consoling thought
no longer if it ever did fits the facts
on the ground
one's chances of rising one generation
to the next
are actually less in the united states
than they are in a great many european
countries
and in canada the chance of rising from
the bottom
fifth of the income scale to the top
is about depending on the study four to
eight percent
even the chance of rising to middle
class
is less than fifty percent so
we need another way of contending with
the deepening inequalities of recent
decades then simply to say
if you go off and get a university
degree then maybe you too will be able
to rise now i've not addressed your
question jesse about
my students i don't want to seem overly
harsh
to them i have no because in many ways
they are deeply engaged
in activities of public service and
good works for their community and for
for the less fortunate so i don't mean
for the moment to suggest
that they are are selfish and
unconcerned with the public good
what i do notice about them which
is telling with regard to the
question of meritocracy is
given what it takes
to compete for entry
into these highly selective u.s
colleges and universities student young
people's
entire adolescent years sometimes
earlier
are converted into a stress-strewn
gauntlet of meritocratic striving
packaging oneself competing for grades
engaging in extracurriculars doing good
works in distant lands
all the better to impress an admissions
committee
it's almost impossible and this much of
the superintended by
often rather pushy parents who may hire
if they can private college consultants
who were experts at the packaging of
these
young people but there is such a
strenuous
insistence on effort and striving and
hard work
that it's almost impos it's almost
impossible
not to emerge from this believing
that winning admission is down to one's
own effort
and one's own doing and so
i'm not so much criticizing my students
as sympathizing with
the wounds that afflict even
the winners because by the time they
arrive many of them
accomplish and gifted
are so driven to achieve
so accustomed to pleasing through
achievement
their parents their teachers the
imagined admissions
committees that they find it difficult
to step back and explore and reflect
and what's worth caring about and what
they they really would
love to study so my my worry is that the
credentialism
is so is crowding out
the love of learning yes i mean the idea
of the free play of the mind that was
supposed to be
the conception of a liberal arts degree
at a university
uh or of uh as it were
a a rounded human being but rounded
by aspiration and interest rather than
by
uh one's curriculum vitae or bio is a
is a is a distant one in this context um
and and i
i thought that was a point well made and
also i think the point about
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas